attorney general william barr says
elected officials should decide the
response to the pandemic
not the scientists it was one of a
series of eye-opening statements that
barr made at a forum last night
he also lashed out at some of the
justice department's own career
officials
as catherine herrich reports barr also
brought up slavery
in the context of the coronavirus
putting a national lockdown stay-at-home
orders
is like house arrest at a conservative
constitution day event in virginia last
night
attorney general bill barr said this of
quarantining nationwide
it's you know other than slavery which
was a different kind of restraint
this is the greatest intrusion on civil
liberties in american history
barr suggested that politicians not
medical professionals
should guide the public during the
pandemic the person in the white coat
is not the grand seer
who who can come up with the right
decision for society
a free people makes its decision through
its elected representative
in the wide-ranging discussion var also
criticized the black lives matter
movement
proposition who can quarrel with the
proposition black lives matter but
they're not interested in black lives
they're interested in they're interested
in
props a small number of blacks who were
killed by police during
a conflict with police usually less than
a dozen a year
who they can use as props to achieve a
much broader political agenda
but the data shows that 250 black people
were killed by police last year alone
black people are more than three times
more likely to be killed during a police
encounter than white people
the attorney general also seemed to take
aim at some of his own people
our prosecutors have all too often
inserted themselves into the political
process
based on the flimsiest of legal theories
barr criticized his prosecutors for
political head hunting
and defended criticism that he ever
interfered in cases involving close
associates
of the president like roger stone and
michael flynn
letting the most junior members set the
agenda might be a good philosophy for a
montessori preschool but it is no way to
run
a federal agency and then denied he's
ever
interfered on mr trump's behalf i'm
saying
what do you mean by interfere under the
law
all prosecutorial power is vested in the
attorney general
and these people are
agents of the attorney general
and as i said fbi agents whose agent do
you think you are
i don't say this in a pompous way but
that that is the chain
of authority and legitimacy
in the department of justice
these remarks come as cbs news has
confirmed that barr encouraged u.s
attorneys on a call last week
to seek federal charges for violent
demonstrators including the rarely used
sedition law
which can lead to fines and imprisonment
for anyone found guilty
of threatening the u.s government
anthony write some statements catherine
thank you very much